there's a programming skill that can  literally change your brain chemistry  and prime it for higher dimensions of  focus  this might sound ridiculous but multiple  peer-reviewed studies have shown this  activity increases white matter  or axons in the brain which is the stuff  that connects neurons together  so what is this amazing skill juggling  yes  that kind of juggling learning how to  juggle is not much different than  learning how to code it takes extreme  focus and many hours of practice not  only will it make you smarter but it  also relieves stress  gets your arms jacked will make women  want to be with you and men want to be  you or vice versa and will make your  resume stand out so grab some parabolas  and get ready for my upcoming juggling  for javascript developers course